Pope Francis is having another big day
on his visit to the US so far on this
trip he's been at the White House he's
addressed Congress what I've been loving
he's watching the Pope drive around
Washington in his popemobile
you gotta love the popemobile and
driving around in it yeah it's a big
deal well this afternoon the Pope left
Washington headed to New York now here's
the problem this story broke just an
hour and a half ago apparently he drove
the popemobile on the wrong Highway yeah
making the transfer from one city to
another and the Pope is missing nobody
knows where he is
I don't know why you're giggling cuz I
think it's a serious this guy is a
stranger he's in a strange land he's
apparently lost somewhere in America in
his popemobile he could I don't know I'm
worried about the guy wearing all white
after Labor Day yeah they're they've
scrambled choppers looking for him
everyone they it's just crazy they don't
what's that Jeff okay I'm just being
fake told that they think they found the
Pope they have a chopper on him right
now let's see if we could there he is
he's climbing pretty fast
[Applause]
he's gonna buy himself when the highway
Wow and he's going pretty good we have
more footage let's see they got more
footage okay the police are after the
Pope and he is he is weaving dangerously
quite recklessly through the crowds if
you're on the highway get out of the way
of the Pope this is best bad
he's just oh wow
what's that and being fake told again
the popemobile was just pulled over
let's see if it's going to resolve
itself
okay the Pope seems to be backing away
he's backing away
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
good pitch up of Rome and they are
cuffing him right now and he's being led
away oh my god let's see that again in
slow motion that was quite exciting yeah
there's the [ __ ] t-boning God's
representative on earth the human vessel
to which God communicates The Vicar of
Christ oh I think so I don't know why
here eh he didn't do anything wrong
he'll talk his way out of it wasn't that
a great clip subscribe to my youtube
channel for an endless supply of me
[Laughter]